خلال سنوات النزاع المستمر في سوريا تسببت
هجمات النظام السوري وحلفائه بمقتل مئات
الالاف وتهجير اكثر من نصف سكان البلاد
ولاحق دمار مادي بالبلاد يقدر باكثر من
117 مليار دولار حتى نهايه العام 2018
بحسب معهد الاقتصاد والسلام
ومع استمرار التدهور في بلد تركت فيه
الحرب دمرا هائلا على الانسان والبنيان
اصبحت سله المساعدات شرط حياه بالنسبه
للكثيرين وغدا ادخال المساعدات الامميه
على راس اجنده الدول وساحه للتفاوض عبر
السنوات اشرفت الامم المتحده على اكبر
استجابه دوليه في ذلك الوقت لتقديم
المساعدات الانسانيه
وصلت حسب مركز الدراسات الاستراتيجيه
والدوليه الى اكثر من اربعين مليار دولار
لكن مصير ذلك الانفاق الاممي بقي محطه
تشكيك وجدل مع اتهامات مستمره للنظام
السوري باستغلاله لصالحه
وجاء زلزال شرق المتوسط في السادس من
فبراير عام 2023 ليضع الجهود الامميه
للاغاثه في سوريا امام تساؤلات تقارن بين
حجم الاحتياجات وبين اليات توفيرها وتاثير
النظام السوري فيها
في هذا التحقيق نفتح ملف المساعدات
الامميه في سوريا
ونتتبع مصيرها
[موسيقى]
مع تصاعد موجه العنف في سوريا ربيع عام
2022 بدات الامم المتحده جهودها بالبحث عن
منفذ لانسياب المساعدات الانسانيه
في السنوات الاولى من الحرب وبينما كان
القتال يتوسع الى مناطق مختلفه من البلاد
وجد ملايين المدنيين انفسهم منقطعين عن
المساعده كما ان العديد منهم كانوا عالقين
في مدن محاصره وفي تلك اللحظه ادرك
المجتمع الدولي وجود مشكله حقيقيه
[موسيقى]
يمكنني القول ان هناك طرقا عديده يحاول
بها النظام السوري التلاعب بالمساعدات او
تحويرها هناك طبقات مختلفه لذلك بعضها
موجود حتى قبل عام 2011 نحن غالبا ما ننسى
انه كان هناك عدد كبير من اللاجئين
الفلسطينيين في سوريا وعدد كبير من
اللاجئين العراقيين
لهذا التحقيق التقينا بمصدر موثوق من
المفوضيه الساميه للامم المتحده لشؤون
اللاجئين والذي ادار فرقا امميه في عده
دول كان من بينها سوريا وافق المصدر على
الادلاء بشهادته شريطه اخفاء هويته صوتا
وصوره ازمه اللاجئين عراقيين عام 2005
كانت الدرس المهم جدا للنظام بالتعامل مع
المنظمات الدوليه نحن كنا بمكتب ميزانيته
800 الف دولار فجاه في ليل ضحاها اجتمع
معنا مدير المكتب بفندق بلودان وقال لنا
اسمعوا
انتو متل يلي كان عم يحلم حلم وتحقق حلمه
نحنا ميزانيتنا 800 الف دولار جايينا 68
مليون دولار نصرفهم خلال هالسنه اخترعوا
لي برامج نصرفها هذا حكي مدير 68 مليون بس
بليله
واللي مع المجتمع الدولي قبل حدوث كل ذلك
لقد عرفت كيف تضع الخطوط الحمراء لم تكن
لتفعل شيئا متسرعا مثل طرد منظمات الاغاثه
الدوليه من البلاد لانها تعلم انه اذا
تمكنت من اقناعها بالبقاء فسيمكنها ذلك من
تامين المزيد من الموارد لحلفائها اي من
اجل مصالحها الخاصه
جاء عمل الامم المتحده على تقديم
الاستجابه الانسانيه في سوريا استنادا الى
قرار الجمعيه العامه رقم 46 على 182 والذي
ينص على ان تقديم المساعده الانسانيه
ينبغي ان يكون بموافقه البلد المتضرر حفظا
لمبدا سياده الدول وان الدوله المتضرره
تؤدي الدوره الاساسيه في الشروع بالمساعده
الانسانيه الا ان الحاله في سوريا كانت
مختلفه في ظل مسؤوليه السلطه عن الكارثه
فاصطدمت الجهود الامميه بالاجراءات
الحكوميه والامنيه السوريه ما دفع وكيله
الامين العام للشؤون الانسانيه فيلر اموس
الى اصدار بيان طالبت فيه الحكومه السوريه
بتامين الوصول غير المقيد للمنظمات
الانسانيه وتوفير مناخ لتقديم المساعده
للمحتاجين بطريقه محيده وغير متحيز
رصدنا تعرض منظمه ميرسي كور لتقييد وصول
وحركه موظفيها في سوريا ثم منعها من العمل
في مناطق النظام تواصلنا مع كل
منظمه ميرسي كور لكنهما امتنعت عن التعليم
لم تقف يوما سوريا وجها في عائق المساعدات
الانسانيه بالعكس يعني الدوله السوريه كل
شعبها الان بحاجه للمساعدات الانسانيه
وبالتالي كان هناك تاسيس للمواقف وكثير من
المنظمات تورطت في ذلك ثم صححت فيما بعد
لاحقا العلاقه مع الحكومه السوريه
الحكومه السوريه وضعت اطار سياسي وقانوني
يسمح لها باستغلال المساعده الانسانيه
لتمويل فضائعها ويعني رعايه مصالحها فوق
مصالح المتضررين وكذلك معاقبه المعارضين
والموالين لها المنظمات والوكالات
الانسانيه العامله في سوريا ليس لها خيار
فقط تستجيب غالبا لمطالب الحكومه حتى وان
كانت عبثيه خوفا من فقدان امكانيه الوصول
الى من يحتاج المساعدات او اغلاق المنظمات
المحليه بصفه شامله
هناك انتهاك صارخ اخر يمكنني ان ارسله وهو
منع وصول المساعدين وليس فقط المساعدات
الى من يحتاجها
هم يوافقون على تاشيرات السفر وبالتالي
يمكنهم الموافقه او الرفض على اي من الذين
يريدوا المجتمع الدولي ارسالهم وبهذا
المستوى فانهم كمن يختاروا لاعبي فريق
الخصم الذي سيلعب امامهم كره القدم في
دمشق هذا هو مستوى التلاعب
في اكثر من موظف تم رفض فيزته في اكثر من
موظف عمل شيء تم طرده في عنا موظفي من
جنسيه امريكيه كانت باجازه في تركيا رفضوا
يعطوها فيزا دخول خلوها بتركيا لانها كانت
يعني تعتبر بالنسبه لهم مشاكسه
فكان هذا الموضوع واضح جدا وكان عنا ضمن
الاجتماعات للموظفين علينا يحكوا اي موظف
في قوه ثوره كلمه ثوره بالمكتب ممكن انه
يلغى عقده وغير مسؤولين عنه في حال وزاره
الخارجيه
المنظمات الدوليه بتصير تعمل بنفس الموضوع
لتنفيذ مشاريعها بتصير تقدم موظفين يتبنوا
السرديه الرسميه ويعتبروا ان الدوله عم
تحارب الارهابيين بكل الاجتماعات بكل
التفاصيل
التقرير اللي بيصدر من المنسقه الانساني
الامومي كان ما يصدر الا بعد انه يقدم
درافت او مسوده لوزاره الخارجيه وزاره
الخارجيه تحدد اي جمل تكون موجوده ضمن هذا
التقرير واي لا
تظهر نسخه مسربه من مسوده خطه الاستجابه
للامم المتحده لعام 2016
خضوعها لتعديلات عديده بعد عرضها على
النظام حيث حذف منها التطرق الى
الانتهاكات مثل الهجمات الجويه على
المنشات الطبيه والاشاره الى المناطق
المحاصره كما حذف اقتراح لدعم ازاله
الالغام
اعتقد ان وكالات الامم المتحده قد اجبرت
على تقديم الكثير من التنازلات عبر السنين
واليوم نحن نتعامل مع تلك التنازلات
واعتقد ان النظام يعيد بالكثير اذا قدموا
تلك التنازلات ويهدد بالكثير ايضا اذا لم
يتم تقديم تلك التنازلات
مثلا هناك بعض المنظمات الدوليه غير
الحكوميه ترفض القول صراحه انها لن تعمل
في المناطق خارج السيطره الحكوميه لن اقول
من هم لكن قيل لهم انهم لا يستطيعون
التسجيل في دمشق وقيل لهم هذا هو السبب
طريقه التعامل مع هدول المنظمات راحت على
طريقين الاولى هو زرع مخبرين ضمن المنظمات
الدوليه
قابلت عده موظفين تم استدعائهم للتحقيق
ضمن هاي المنظمات وضلوا حوالي عشره ايام
على مراجعات شبه يوميه بعد التحقيقات وبعد
المساءلات عن اعمال المنظمه بالكامل انعرض
عليهم يجندوهم لصالح اجهزه الاستخبارات
الفكره الثانيه هو فرض مبالغ ماليه او
اطارات على المنظمات الدوليه اللي عم
تحاول توزع بسوريا مثلا بجنوب دمشق في
منظمه الاونروا مخصصه لتوزيع للاجئين
الفلسطينيين فالمنظمه في الها مركز رئيسي
ضمن مخيم اليرموك ومخيم اليرموك ممنوع
الدخول اليه حاولت 2020
توزيع مساعدات للاجئين الفلسطينيين حطوهم
بخيار اما دفع مليون او العمليه بدها تفجر
نهائيا ما بيقدروا
احدى الطرق التي يعني يستفيد من خلالها
النظام السوري من المساعدات الامميه هو من
خلال اجبار المؤسسات الامميه على توظيف
اشخاص مقربين منه وهناك يعني العديد من
الامثله ولكن هنا اذكر زوجه يعني وزير
الخارجيه الحالي فيصل المقداد والتي تم
تعيينها كمستشاره نفسيه
لمنظمه الصحه العالميه العامله في دمشق
تكشف قوائم اسميه مسربه من الاونروا حصول
عناصر من المخابرات السوريه ومقاتلين من
الميليشيات المواليه للنظام على قروض من
برنامجها للتمويل الصغير الاقراض كما تظهر
قوائم اسميه عمل عليها الصحفي احمد عبيد
شكلا اخر من اشكال التلاعب بالمساعدات
الامميه
موضوع السرقات عن طريق القوائم الاسميه
ضمن المراكز الصغيره بالبلدات او بالمدن
مثلا بحاله شخصيه كانت بجديده عرطوز يعني
خلال من خلال البحث
والتقصي تبين في 7000 اسم منهم اسماء
وهميه منهم اسماء مهجره منهم اسماء
معتقلين انهم اسماء متوفين هدول الاشخاص
بيتم استلام حصصهم كل 40 يوم نقطه ثانيه
اشخاص الممنوعين من الاستلام بناء على
موقفهم السياسي
لقد وجدنا هذا فعلا مع برنامج الغذاء
العالمي حيث كانت هناك اسماء معينه مكتوب
بجانبها امن واولئك الاشخاص كان عليهم
الذهاب الى فرع الامن المحلي من اجل
التسويه وضعهم او اصلاح وضعهم مع الحكومه
قبل تلقي السله الغذائيه اعتقد بان هناك
قد يكون هناك حالات فرديه لا ادري ولكن
اعتقد بان الامم المتحده لم تكن لتسكت عن
هذه الاخطاء اصلا وكانت هناك فضيحه اذا
كان هذا الكلام صحيحا يعني اليوم اعتقد
بانه لا يوجد لا قرود ولا امن سياسي في
هذا الموضوع ولكل هذه الفبركات التي تحدث
يعني انا من الاشخاص اللي شاهدت بام العين
كيف تتم توزيع المساعدات
هناك عوامل اخرى برزت ضمن عمليات التوزيع
اظهرت ايضا مساوئ كبيره ضمن عمليه التوزيع
والمساعدات الانسانيه على سبيل المثال
الالتزام بشركاء محدودين وتحديد الشريك
التجاري الذي يتعامل كمزود خدمه مع وكاله
الامم المتحده وبالتالي هذا ساهم باسراء
هذه الشركات التي تدور في فلك النظام بشكل
اساسي وسمح لهذه الشركات بالحصول على عقود
من الامم المتحده رغم انها شركات معاقبه
من قبل الولايات المتحده ومن قبل الاتحاد
الاوروبي
بالعوده الى تقارير المشتريات الخاصه
بالامم المتحده وجدنا انها قد صرحت عن دفع
اكثر من مليار دولار كقيمه اجماليه
للمشتريات داخل سوريا بين عامي 2015
و2020 من بين تلك المشتريات ما حصلت عليه
شخصيات وشركات مقربه من النظام بعضها خاضع
للعقوبات مثل فندق فورسيزن دمشق وشركه
سيرياتيل وشركه شروق وشركه قاسيون
عندما تسال وكالات الامم المتحده عن هذا
يقولون انهم لا يتعينوا عليهم الالتزام
بالعقوبات الامريكيه والاوروبيه لكن
بالمقابل يتعين على الوكالات الامميه
الالتزام بقواعد السلوك الموردين الخاصه
بهم والتي تشير الى انهم لا يستطيعون
التعاقد مع شخص مسؤولا مثلا عن انتهاكات
حقوق الانسان المبالغ التي تدفعها الامم
المتحده في سوريا يمكن تقسيمها الى شقين
شق يتم دفعه خارج سوريا لشراء مواد
بغالبيتها مواد غذائيه ومن ثم ارسالها الى
سوريا ولكن هناك ايضا مبالغ يتم انفاقها
في داخل سوريا من ضمنها على سبيل المثال
العقود عقود المشتريات مع مؤسسات موجوده
في الداخل السوري يتمحب الاموال في هذه
الطبقه الثانيه من خلال النظام النقدي
السوق السوداء عمليا هي تعكس واقع القوه
الشرائيه لليره السوريه بشكل افضل بكثير
من السعر يفرضه البنك المركزي تظهر نشره
سعر الصرف الصادره عن مصرف سوريا المركزي
منتصف عام 2020 استلام المنظمات الدوليه
لاموالها المحوله الى سوريا بسعر 700 ليره
لكل دولار فيما كان سعره الفعلي في السوق
المحلي
2560 ليره للدولار الواحد في ذات اليوم
بتاثير الفرق بين السعر الرسمي وسعر السوق
رصدنا ضياع 37 بالمئه من تمويل الجهد
الاممي واجور العاملين لسنوات بمجرد
وصولها الى البنوك السوريه
مثل ذلك هدرا كبيرا وغنيمه سانحه ساعدت
حكومه النظام على جمع المكاسب من دول يطبق
معظمها عقوبات بحقه
[موسيقى]
من خلال سعر الصرف والذي يتعلق باي عمله
اجنبيه تدخل الى سوريا ويلزم تحويلها الى
الليره السوريه نحن نعلم انه بين عام 2020
2021 تم اختلاس 100 مليون دولار على الاقل
بهذه الطريقه وضح هنا ان الارقام تمثل فقط
الحد الادنى من المبالغ التي تخسرها الدول
المتبرعه عندما ترسل حوالات ماليه الى
دمشق وذلك لعدم مقدرتنا على معرفه
هويه بعض المتعاقدين لكون الامم المتحده
ترفض الافصاح عن هويتهم اذا ما انتقلنا
الى الفتره يعني الاقرب الينا الان لنقل
العامين 2020 و2021 نجد ان البيانات
الامميه تدعي بان الهلال الاحمر العربي
السوري وكذلك الامانه السوريه للتنميه لم
تحصل على اي تمويل من مؤسسات امميه طبعا
نعلم بان هذه المؤسسات عمادها هو الانفاق
الذي يعني
تعمل به الامم المتحده
بحسب بروتوكولات الامم المتحده فانها
تلتزم بالعمل مع شركاء محليين تنفيذيين في
سوريا يوافق عليهم النظام في مناطق سيطرته
قمنا بمراجعه تقارير الشفافيه الخاصه
بالامم المتحده ووجدنا ان المنظمات
الدوليه لا تلزم اولئك الشركاء بالكشف عن
الجهات التي يتعاقدون معها من الباطن وهو
ما فسر عدم ظهور اسماء كل الفاعلين في
تنفيذ عقود الامم المتحده وجعل الوصول
اليهم عبر منصات الشفافيه مهمه مستحيله
الا ان اكبر الشركاء المحليين كانوا شديد
الوضوح والعلنيه
[موسيقى]
هو استغل قرار الجمعيه العامه في الزام
ومتحده بالعمل مع الدوله كجزء من سيادتها
في توزيع المساعدات فيقوم كافه منظمات
الامم المتحده بالعمل اما مع الهلال
الاحمر وهو بشكل اساسي المقاول الاول او
من خلال منظمات اخرى فتره من الفترات كانت
بستان ايضا جمعيه الامانه السوريه
للامانه اختاري التراب الوطن مع كامل
الانحياز
لسوريا لترابا
وللي ضحوا كرماله
وشبكه الامانه السوريه للتنميه والتي
تتبعها مرصد الشبكات السياسيه والاقتصاديه
عن ارتباطها المباشر باسماء الاسد وتظهر
سيطرتها على الكثير من المؤسسات والبرامج
والصناديق الاخرى كما كشفت تقارير الامانه
عن وفره ماليه مكنتها من بناء شبكه
استثمارات مرتبطه بمتنفذين مقربين من
النظام
الامانه السوريه هي بنت افكار اسماء الاسد
اسماء الاسد التي يعني
مسكت رايه
التحديث النظام السوري وعصرنته وكما ظهرت
يعني مثلا في عده مجلات ورده دمشق ورده
الصحراء والى اخره وكان جزء من هذه الصوره
وتراس منظمه كبيره عن مستوى المجتمع
المدني تقوم على تحديث المجتمع ولذا نرى
ان الامان العامه في بدايتها الى يعني الى
قيام الثوره السوريه هي كان عملها بشكل
اساسي
بالجانب التعليمي والثقافي والحوكمي لم
تقترب ابدا من الاعمال الاغاثيه والاعمال
الانسانيه
[موسيقى]
تظهر هذه البرامج انحياز الامانه السوريه
ودورها في مسانده النشاطات السياسيه
والعسكريه للنظام رغم انها تخضع للقانون
السوري رقم 93 لعام
1958 الذي يحضر على الجمعيات السوريه
الانخراط في اي نشاط سياسي او عسكري
خطوط الحمراء بوقت مبكر جدا حول اي من
المنظمات غير الحكوميه يمكن ان تعمل هناك
وعبر اي من الوكالات لذلك غالبيه
المساعدات الان يتم تنفيذها من خلال
الهلال الاحمر السوري والذي يعتبر الى حد
كبير منظمه تابعه للحكومه عاده تقوم
منظمات الامم المتحده بتسليم قوافلها
بنفسها الى المحتاجين وحتى ان تعاملت مع
شركاء منفذين فانهم لا يكونون تابعين
للحكومه هي لا تاخذ مرافقه عسكريه تابعه
للحكومه او اشياء كهذه لكن في سوريا لديك
الهلال الاحمر السوري والذي يقوم بتسليم
المساعدات الامميه مع مرافقه من الجيش
النظامي
يعد الهلال الاحمر العربي السوري اكبر
منظمه اغاثيه تعمل اليوم في سوريا بعدد
عاملين تجاوز
14,800 موظف ومتطوع
[موسيقى]
تظهر شبكه الكيانات والاشخاص المرتبطين
بالهلال الاحمر مجموعه من المتنفذين
المقربين من النظام ابتداء بالمدير الحالي
خالد حبوباتي المعين بقرار حكومي ورئيس
اتحاد غرف التجاره السوريه راتب الشلاح
اضافه الى وزير الخارجيه السابق وليد
المعلم
الهلال الاحمر العربي السوري كمؤسسه في
مسار جدل وخلاف كبير عليها كمؤسسه انسانيه
لا نستطيع ان نطلب عدم اشراكها وعدم لعب
دورها لكن كمؤسسه مستفيده من دور اجهزه
الامن وتلعب دور متعاون مع اجهزه
الاستخبارات وايضا هناك مخاوف انها تساعد
اجهزه الامن ببعض الملفات مثل التهرب من
العقوبات او الاشتراك بعقود مع اشخاص
معاقبين دوليا وحابب اميز هنا بشكل دقيق
بين عناصر الهلال الاحمر العربي السوري
الجنود المجهولين اللي وزعوا المساعدات
تعرضوا يعني احد احد الاشخاص تعرض للقنص
براسه الثوره كان المسعف حكم السباعي وبين
القيادات الهلال الاحمر العربي السوري
واللي انا شفتهم بمؤتمر بروكسل ب 2018 و
2019 قدموا لمؤتمر الاتحاد الاوروبي
بروكسل مع رساله واضحه رفع العقوبات عن
النظام السوري لان العقوبات هي من يجوع
السوريين
تفسروا وثيقه مسربه من الامن السياسي
النفوذ الذي يتمتع به الهلال الاحمر اذ
تكشف عن وجود توجيهات امنيه باعطائه
الدوره المركزيه في توزيع المساعدات
وتعزيز موقفه امام الوكالات الدوليه
التقينا بمصدر عمل لسنوات في الهلال
الاحمر السوري وافق على الادلاء بشهادته
شرط اخفاء هويته تدخل الامن بعمل الهلال
كان تدخل قوي وعنيف
يعني تخيل انه اذا بدك تحرك سياره اسعاف
لمنطقه فيها كان مظاهره وصار فيها مصابين
بدك تاخد موافقه من بدك تاخذ تنقل شاحنه
او تحرك ساحنه
لمنطقه فيها مظاهرات كان بدك موافقه امنيه
مع اشتداد المعارك بمدينه حلب وهذا ما صار
في نوعا ما انقسام جغرافي بالمناطق بين
المناطق النظام ومناطق المعارضه زاد
النظام من شراسته من مراقبته للعمل
الانساني على الهلال بتدخل بادنى التفاصيل
وبطلب موافقات احيانا كثير برفضى يعني انا
شهدت على طلب عدد معين من الحصص من قبل
افرع الامنيه او من قبل ضباط كانوا يطلبوا
بشكل مباشر حصه
لحتى
مشوا لنا الشغل او ما يعرضوا العناصر
الميدانيه بالهلال الاحمر لمضايقات شد انه
بتيجي سيارات وتعبئ سلل سيارات امنيه
وتعبي حصص من مركز الهلال وتروح
يظهر مقطع صوره ناشطون في فرع الامن
السياسي بادلب استمرار تلك الظاهره حيث
عثر على حصص غذائيه اغاثيه داخل فرع الامن
عقب السيطره قوات المعارضه على المدينه
عام 2015
كما تشير صور مسربه الى استخدام النظام
لمساعدات الامم المتحده في غير اغراضها
المفترضه
[موسيقى]
من بين المؤسسات المتحكمه بالمساعدات
الدوليه في مناطق السيطره النظام تبرز الى
الواجهه جمعيه البستان الخيريه التي اسسها
رامي مخلوف ابن خالي الاسد
رصدن اعلان جمعيه البستان عن حمله توزيع
بشراكه مع اليونيسف والتي قدمت تمويلا
للجمعيه بقيمه 268 الف دولار عام 2015
بحسب صحيفه الجارديان
اللافت ان شبكه ارتباطات جمعيه البستان
تكشف عن علاقه واضحه بتمويل عدد من
الميليشيات المحليه التي تقاتل الى جانب
النظام في مختلف المناطق السوريه
[موسيقى]
جمعيه البستان كانت جمعيه صغيره جدا تعنى
بالمساعدات على العلاج في في اللاذقيه على
مستوى محلي توسعت بشكل كبير جدا في سنوات
الاولى للثوره السوريه بالذات في
المجتمعات المحليه الداعمه
والمواليه للنظام بمحافظه اللاذقيه وطرطوس
وفي اجزاء كبيره من محافظه حماه وحمص وتم
توظيف
الجزء الاكبر من المساعدات الانسانيه من
اجل تجيش ابناء المجتمعات المحليه اما من
العمل وتطوع مع جيش السوري او من العمل
والتطوع مع الميليشيات التابعه لقوات
الدفاع الوطني الجمعيه البستان عملت بعده
مناطق على تجنيد الاشخاص عن طريق
المساعدات الاغاثيه او المساعدات الماليه
بشكل عام فكان في تجنيد المقاتلين خاصه
بالمدن الساحليه وبجنوب سوريا
بالبحث في المصادر المفتوحه وجدنا عشرات
المقاطع التي توثق نشاطا عسكريا واسعا
للميليشيات التابعه لجمعيه البستان والتي
كان من ابرزها قوات الكميت هذه الفصيله
التي نتكلم عنه كان يحمي فرق الاغاثه
بجمعيه البستان يعني لا يع يكون هناك
جمعيه يقتل افرادها وهم يساعدون الناس
لذلك كان هناك تمويل من جمعيه البستان ليس
معيبا ذلك يعني ليس معيب ان يكون هناك
مجموعه تحرس
مخازن من يحرس مخازن جمعيه البستان من
يحرس اولئك الاشخاص الذين يذهبون الى
مناطق ساخنه هم اعضاء في جمعيه البستان
لكن مقابله صحفيه مع فراس عيسى القيادي في
قوات الكميد تكشف تفاصيل مختلفه عن طبيعه
عملها
جمعيه البستان بالاساس جمعيه خيريه شكلت
الجناح العسكري بعام 2012 رواتب من
الاستاذ رامي مخلوف نحن بنعتبر الرديف
الاول للجويه كتيبه الكوميت المهام الخاصه
مفرزه مع حمله النمر يعني نحن اغلب
تواجدنا بالمعارك مع قوات النمر التسليح
من اداره المخابرات الجويه حمله النمر كل
رواتب مقاتلها من جمعيه البستان يعني
الامور الماليه الجمعيه بتتوولاها والامور
القتاليه والتسليح اداره المخابرات الجويه
بتتولعها
[موسيقى]
تشكيل قوات الكميت بعمل 2013 اولى مهام
التشكيل كانت حمايه حقول الجزل وشاعر
والمهر وحيان النفطيه انتهت مهمتنا بحمايه
الحقول بعمل 2015 شاركنا بمعركه حلب
الكبرى ومعركه حماه الريف الشمالي
خضع التحركات الامم المتحده في مناطق
النظام الى رقابه مشدده كما تظهر وثيقه
مسربه صادره عن مكتب الامم المتحده في
طرطوس موجهه الى محافظ ادلب في ذلك الوقت
صفوان سليمان والذي احالها بدوره الى رئيس
اللجنه الامنيه ورئيس فرع الامن السياسي
وقائد الشرطه
تظهر وثيقه اخرى ان وكالات امميه كانت
مستاءه من تدخل عناصر الامن في عملها
وقدمت الشكاوى بذلك الى وزاره الخارجيه
السوريه وهو ما اقرت به شعبه الامن
السياسي في تعقيبها على الشكاوى كما قدمت
الامم المتحده قائمه بالمناطق التي تواجه
صعوبه في الوصول اليها والتي اظهرت ان
مناطق واسعه من الاراضي السوريه كانت
محرومه من الحصول على المساعدات
الواقع السوري هو مو منطقه ضربه زلزال هو
مو منطقه صار فيها فيضان وبالتالي
الاحتياجات اللي بدها تدخل الى المناطق
السوريه تختلف
كليا عن اللي تعودت المنظمات الدخله الى
مناطق اخرى في العالم نحن كنا تحت عوج
شديد بادخال المواد الطبيه وكنا بنتامل
انه هاي القوافل يكون الحل فيها نحن كثير
كلنا نستغرب انه بتشوف انت على الاعلام
قافله طويله عريضه 30 40 سياره بس لما
بتلاقي انت خمس ست سيارات او ربع هاي
القافله هو عباره عن جالونات تعبئه مياه
فاضيه وخيام وادويه شامبوات امل وشامبوات
جرب بتقول انا ما هي احتياجاتي انا عم
بتعرض للموت اليومي انا عندي قصف يومي انا
اللي بحتاجه بحتاج سيرومات بحتاج اكياس دم
بيحتاج مواد تخدير بيحتاج مواد جراحيه كنا
نزودهم في كل دخول بملف ورقي اسمه
احتياجات الغوطه الطبيه لكن بالنهايه
كانوا هنن محكومين ببروتوكولاتهم من جهه
وبوسايه ورقابه النظ من جهه اخرى
انه انتم تاخرتوا شهر هاي القافله كان
لازم من شهر حسب البرنامج اللي انتم
مصدرينه بتدخل كان الجواب عندهم انه
النظام ما سمح لنا احنا مجهزينها من شهر
بس ما سمحت
فالعمليه من الفا الى باء هاء هي تحت سلطه
اجهزه امن النظام ما كان عندهم استقلاليه
القوافل تساهم بحلوه الحل الحقيقي هو فتح
معبر
بالتاكيد هناك الكثير من الاشخاص الذين
يقولون حتى وان كان بامكانك ايصال سله
غذائيه واحده الى شخص واحد اذا عليك
البقاء وايصالها اعتقد ان المشكله في هذا
الطرح انه عندما تطبق ذلك على نطاق واسع
كما راينا في سوريا عليك ان تحاول فهم ما
يحدث مع الف سله غذائيه اخرى او الالف
دولار الاخر في حالات الحصار تمكنا من
ايصال المساعدات الى المناطق المحاصره لكن
في كثير من الاحيان 40% على الاقل من
مجموع تلك المساعدات كان يصرف في سبيل
ايصالها الى تلك الاماكن وهذا عزز من
اقتصاد الحرب وربما اطال من امد الحصار
تثبت الوثائق المسربه من الامن السياسي
تحكم النظام المطلق بوصول المساعدات الى
المناطق المحاصره اذ تشدد على ان السماح
بوصولها يحتاج الى قرار سياسي مسبق يشرف
عليه مكتب الامن الوطني مع ضباط شعبه
الامن السياسي كما ترفق الوثائق قائمه
تحدد ضابطا امنيا لكل محافظه سوريه يكون
مسؤولا عن اداره ملف وصول المساعدات اليها
تؤكد الوثائق صحه تقارير منظمتي
التي تحدثت عن سيطره السلطات السوريه على
توزيع المساعدات وقدره افرع المخابرات على
تجميد القوافل الاغاثيه وفق اعتبارات
سياسيه وليست انسانيه
الحصول على الموافقه المسبقه تخصيص
المناطق بشكل مناطق ساخنه ومناطق امنه منع
وصول مساعدات بشكل رئيسي لمناطق محدده
تخصيص ضباط امن مسؤولين لاعطاء الموافقه
ميدانيا بشكل رئيسي وايضا الحصول على
جداول الاحتياج كل هذا قدم ادله اكثر من
واضحه مئه بالمئه بوثائق مكتوبه وموقعه
باسماع هؤلاء الضباط بخط ايديهم
بتوقيعاتهم على توزيع المساعدات الانسانيه
خضع للاعتبارات السياسيه وللتلاعب السياسي
والامني من قبل النظام واستخدم كماده اداه
حرب استخدام كسلاح ضد المدنيين
اكثر من هيك صراحه حقيقه كسياسه ممنهجه
لدوله محاصره شعب وتجويعه والتحكم بدخول
مساعداته الانسانيه لا اعتقد انه حصل في
التاريخ كانت موثقه بشكل برقراطي روتيني
من قبل اجهزه الامن نفسه الحكومه السوريه
خلقت عوائق كبيره امام تقديم المساعدات في
بعض المناطق او في عباره اخرى استخدام
المساعدات الانسانيه لمعاقبه المعارضين
وجزاء الموالين خلينا نعطيكم مثال حي في
هناك بلده اسمها حرسته وهي بلده في الغوطه
الشرقيه فيها تقريبا 600 شخص بحاجه الى
المساعده منهم تقريبا 400 كانوا نازحين
لكن هناك بلده اخرى ثانيه في الغوطه
الشرقيه هي دوما وعدد سكانها 94 الف نسمه
في حاجه الى المساعده فكل وضوح حاجيات دون
اكثر لحاحا بكثير مما عليه في حرستا لكن
رغم كل هذا لم تتلقى دوما سوى جزء ضئيل
دعم اعاده التاهيل الذي تلقته حرص لماذا
لان سكان الحرص تعادوا الى حد كبير من
المناطق المواليه للحكومه بينما في د
ومه يعيشون تحت قياده جماعه جيش الاسلام
المناهده للحكومه ورفضوا المغادره عندما
اجلي السكان فيعني لا توجد برامج انسانيه
حسب علمنا وحسب المؤشرات الامميه التي
نتوفر عنها لا توجد برامج انسانيه في دوما
باستثناء خزاني مياه لصليب الاحمر
رغم تنسيقها المسبق مع النظام السوري
وحصولها على الموافقات اللازمه تعرضت عده
قوافل للامم المتحده والمؤسسات الشريكه
معها للاستهداف المباشر
رصدنا وقوع غاره جويه في العشرين من
سبتمبر عام 2016
استهدفت قافله تابعه للامم المتحده
والهلال الاحمر كانت قد خرجت بعد حصولها
على الموافقه من مناطق سيطره النظام في
حلب الى بلده اورم الكبرى
ادت الغاره الى مقتل ما لا يقل عن 14
مدنيا بينهم عمر بركات منسق الهلال الاحمر
في مناطق المعارضه وعن تدمير 17 شاحنه
[موسيقى]
الا ان تقرير لجنه التحقيق الخاصه التي
شكلتها الامم المتحده اكد مسؤوليه النظام
عن الهجوم الذي تم بالمروحيات والطائرات
الحربيه مشيرا الى تعمده استهداف القافله
وايقاع اكبر ضرر ممكن فيها وعلى نطاق اوسع
فقد تعرضت المنشات الطبيه المدعومه دوليا
الى اكثر من 600 غاره جويه ادت الى مقتل
930 موظفا على الاقل
طبعا هذا المفروض اصلا من الامم المتحده
بالتسييس اللي حدث وقتها كانوا كل يوم
يسوي ايداني لم يسمى النظام السوري كل يوم
يعني اذا بدنا نتنفس كان لازم يكون في عنا
احنا امميه سيدي هذا تسييس غير مقبول
نهائيا
العديد من العاملين في المجال الانساني
خلال هذه الحرب واعتقد ان عدد القتل في
ادلب وشمال غرب سوريا يفوق عدد القتلى في
اي جزء اخر من سوريا في السنوات الثلاث
الماضيه قتل اكثر من عشرين شخصا هؤلاء هم
في الغالب سوريون يعملون في منظمات تم
دعمها من قبل الامم المتحده انه مكان خطير
جدا جدا للعمل
كثير في زملاء يتعرضوا للاعتقال احيانا
منهم لعده ايام احيانا
منهم لفترات طويله انا من الاشخاص اللي
تعرضت للاعتقال عام 2012
بسبب عملي بالهلال الاحمر توجهت لي تهمه
نقل اسلحه وذخائر ضمن مساعدات اللي كانت
تطلع من حلب لحمص طبعا انا ما زرت في
حياتي حمص ما اشتغلت بحياتي بموضوع
الاسلحه والى اخره كان عملي انساني بحث
كنت حاول اجمع مساعدات عينيه من البسه
اغذيه لاقي متبرعين بفتره حمص وضع صعب
[موسيقى]
ما كان ينبغي لهذا القرار ان يكون ضروريه
لا ينبغي للمساعدات الانسانيه ان تكون
موضوعا للتفاوض فهي التزام ينبغي ان ينفذ
بموجب القانون الدولي
عام 2014 ومع اتساع رقعه المناطق الخارجه
عن سيطره النظام وعرقله اصول بعثات الامم
المتحده اليها اصدر مجلس الامن القرار
والذي يقضي بادخال المساعدات عبر الحدود
دون المرور بدمشق
[موسيقى]
كان هناك اجماع حقيقي في مجلس الامن حول
الحاجه الى ايجاد طرق لضمان تلبيه
احتياجات المدني ولم تجري الامور كما كان
يفترض بها اعتمادا على موافقات الحكومه
السوريه والتي كانت طرفا في النزاع كانت
الطريق مسدودا والعديد من المدنيين لم
يكونوا يتلقون المساعده تماما في اللحظه
التي صدر فيها القرار تمكنت الامم المتحده
من انشاء عمليه اللوجستيه ضخمه في الواقع
لقد اصبحت اكبر عمليه انسانيه في العالم
في ذلك الوقت كان لدينا فريق من مراقبي
الامم المتحده الذين يراقبون كل شاحنه
مساعدات تعبر الحدوث كان علينا التاكد من
نزاهه عمليه المساعده هذه
مكانه صدور القرار
2265 الامم المتحده من ايصال المساعدات
خارج سيطره النظام وبعيدا عن سطوته
بشراكه مع عشرات الجمعيات الاغاثيه كما
قامت بمراقبتها وضبط عملها
توجهنا الى جمعيه عطاء للاغاثه الانسانيه
لتحدثنا عن تفاصيل هذه الشراكه بعد صدور
قرار دخلت الامم المتحده وصار عندها مكتب
تنسيق في مقره في غازي عنتاب
اصبحت المنظمات الدوليه
تدخل صندوق الغذاء العالمي تغير المشهد
تماما بوجود تمويل يقدر بمئات الملايين
صار دخوله للشمال السوري طبعا كونهن لا
يستطيع يعني الوصول للداخل فحياتنا عمله
رفع قدرات كبيره للمنظمات المحليه وحطوا
شروط رقابه شديده يعني اليوم المنحه اللي
توصلنا انا نحن بنحكي نحن كمؤسسه انه بكون
عنا ثلاث مستويات من الرقابه مستوى
المنظمه المانحه مستوى الاجراءات اللي
بيطلبوها منك سياسات داخليه ايضا بيجينا
شركات تدقيق خارجيه وبتكون يعني على مستوى
دولي هي اللي عم تجيب بتدقق علينا بمستوى
الصرف حتى التعيين يعني دخلوا سيفيات
الناس الموظفين اللي عنا
في شهر يوليو من كل عام يحل موعد التصويت
على القرار
[موسيقى]
من الشعب السوري حاليا في حاله من الفقر
بحسب احصائيات امميه كذلك لولا المساعدات
الامميه الكثير من العائلات سوف تدخل في
حاله من المجاعه بشكل مباشر يعني خلال
بضعه ايام سوف سوف لن تستطيع تامين
الاساسيات المرتبطه بالغذاء او الماوى
يشير تقرير منسقي الاستجابه الصادر في
يناير 2023 الى ان نسبه تغطيه الاستجابه
الانسانيه للاحتياجات متداعيه بالاساس اذ
بلغت نسبه العجز
83% في قطاعي الصحه والتغذيه وواحد وستين
في المئه في مجال التعليم بينما بلغت 55%
من احتياجات الايواء والسكن
كان جزء من المفاوضات والتنازلات التي
قدمتها مجموعه الدول الاصدقاء الشعبي
السوري لروسيا هو عدم
اطلاق القرار بشكل كامل على فتره غير
محدوده وانما تجديد بشكل سنوي فالقرار تبع
قرار التمرير المساعدات
2165 هو بالاصل يعني ايضا في روحه مؤقت
وليس وليس دائما
حاولت روسيا الضغط لمنع تجديد قرار
مساعدات الامميه العابره للحدود في رساله
سياسيه نحن انتصرنا عسكريا ايضا نصرف هذا
النصر العسكري بنصر سياسي نصر السياسي
يعيد التوزيع حصرا عبر دمشق ومرورا بدمشق
لذلك الدوره الروسي كان كان اكثر من
بالملف الانساني محاوله اجهاض الملف
الانساني وابتزاز الولايات المتحده
والمجتمع الدولي فيه حقيقه يوازي ان لم
يكن اسوا للدوله الروسي بالقصف والتهجير
وقتل السوريين لانه يعرض حياه السوريين
لخطر
اليوم معظم الناس اللي موجوده في الشمال
السوري يلعب توصل للمساعدات عبر الحدود هي
اما كانت تحت الحصار في الغوطه او في حمص
او من المناطق اللي هجروا مننا من ريف
حماه هدول صار عندهم تجربه سابقه قبل هيك
ما كانت المساعدات بايد النظام وعجزت
الامم المتحده في فك الحصار عن الزبداني
وعن الغوطه وبالنهايه وصلوا لحل التهجير
وحملوهم بالباصات الخضر اليوم كيف ستقنع
الناس اللي جربوا عندما يترك النظام كان
متحكم بالمساعدات كيف عاملهم هو جوهم اللي
اضطر وراء الشجر اليوم هل سيكون هناك ثقه
ان نعيد ان نسلم النظام التحكم في مساعدات
تمرين مساعدات ونفترض افتراضا شو اللي
تغير بالنظام ولا شيء يعني اعتقد هذا
سيهدد فعليا منظومه العمل الانساني كله في
مقتل
نحن كمنظمات يعني وجدت من اجل مساعده هذول
الناس ما عنا بديل غير المساعده سواء كانت
وقف القرار ولا ما توقفت احنا ما وجدنا
بقرار ولذلك سنستمر ممكن اليوم يضعف
عملناه بس الاكيد انه ما راح نتخلى عن
الناس لانه هاي الرساله اللي املنا فيها
نحن اليوم العمل الانساني يجب باي حال من
الاحوال ان لا يرتبط باجنده سياسيه او
نفوت قوه في هذا الموضوع لانه اليوم حياه
البشر ما لازم تكون للورقه للمساومه
[موسيقى]
هذا القرار عبر الحدود قد انقذ حقا ملايين
الارواح لقد كان ناجحا للغايه في تمكيننا
من مراقبه جميع المساعدات التي يتم
ادخالها والتاكد منه وصول المساعدات الى
الاشخاص الذين يحتاجونها
لماذا تفككون اليه تم انشاؤها بدعم من
المجتمع الدولي والتي اقرها مجلس الامن في
عدد من القرارات المختلفه على مر السنين
لماذا تفككون ذلك الان في اللحظه التي
فيها الناس اكثر ما يحتاجون للمساعده
لماذا تضعفون هذه العمليه الانسانيه الان
بينما لا تزال هناك حاجات ماسه لها
مع اعاده قوات النظام السيطره الميدانيه
على معظم الاراضي السوريه عمل النظام
وحليفه الروسي على الترويج لاعاده
اللاجئين وحث الدول المانحه على تمويل
اعاده الاعمار الا ان هذه الدعوات ما زالت
موضعه تشكيك الكثيرين وتخوفهم من
استخدامها لتعزيز مكاسب مجرمي الحرب في
سوريا
وجدنا ان الامم المتحده قدمت تمويلا
للامانه السوريه للتنميه عام 2017 لازاله
الانقاض في حلب الشرقيه وهو ما وثقته
الامانه في تقريرها السنوي
فيلق المدافعين عن حلب الذي كان مسؤولا
بشكل اساسي على الاقل جزئيا عن التهجير
القسري من حلب تم التعاقد معه من قبل شعبه
مشتريات الامم المتحده للقيام بازاله
الانقاض في تلك المنطقه نفسها
والمشكله هي انه غالبا لا يكون الامر
بالضروره باسم المدافعين عن حلب فكما هو
واضح لا يتم التعاقد معهم من قبل وكاله
امميه تحت هذا الاسم ستكون العقود تابعه
لشركه قاموا بتاسيسها من اجل الحصول على
عقود مع الامم المتحده او مع شركات اخرى
سيكون هناك الكثير من الفساد هكذا كان
الحال قبل عام 2011 تحدثت الى شخص يعمل مع
وكاله اخرى للاونروا كان من المفترض ان
يشرف بشكل اساسي على اعاده تاهيل بعض
الاحياء الفلسطينيه وكان الفساد مستشريا
حتى في ذلك الوقت
غالبا اليوم اي عمليه اعاده اعمار يقوم
بتنظيمها النظام سوف تقوم بالقضاء على
المجتمعات المحليه الحاضنه للثوره السوريه
او الحاضنه لاي عمليه تمرد عليه لاحقا من
خلال تدميرها
تفتيتها تشتيتها عدم سماح لهم بوجود في
مناطق في مناطق مركزه
وهذا يعني بدا فيه اصلا من خلال استهداف
هذه المجتمعات المحليه في البنى التحتيه
في تدمير المنازل في تدمير الطرق في تدمير
المشافي اما الطريقه الثانيه فهو من سوف
يقوم بعمليه ثاني تنفيذ هذه المشاريع
في غياب الشفافيه او الرقابه او الضمانات
الفعاله على الفاعلين في المجال الانساني
وكذلك على المالحين توخي الحضاره الشديد
لان هناك خطر حقيقي يتمثل في اعاده توجيه
تمويل المعونه واعاده الاعمار نحو تمكين
وتقويه الجهات المنتهكه ما يفاقم الظلم ضد
المدنيين وما يطيل المعاناه في سوريا
سيكون الامر اسوا بكثير في سوريا انا
اعتقد ايضا انه سيفتح الباب لزياده
مستويات العنف لان هذا التمويل سيعاد
توجيهه بشكل اساسي الى الحكومه التي قتلت
شعبها
هناك حاجه للمراقبه مراقبه افضل مساءله
افضل تدقيق افضل هذا يجب ان يحدث التدقيق
التقييم المراقبه يجب ان تتم بغض النظر عن
الوضع السياسي على الارض
استفاق العالم فجر السادس من فبراير على
زلزال مدمر فتك بارواح اكثر من سته الاف
شخص في سوريا واكثر من 47 الفا في تركيا
تدفقت مساعدات حكوميه ودوليه نحو مطارات
النظام السوري في حين تلكت جهود مسانده
نحو مليون متضررا في المناطق الخارجه عن
سيطرته كما عبر عن ذلك وكيل الامين العام
للشؤون الانسانيه ومنسق لاغاثه في حالات
الطوارئ مارتن جريفيث واحتاجت الامم
المتحده لزياره دمشق للحصول على موافقه
النظام على ادخال المساعدات الى مناطق
المعارضه عبر معبرين اضافيين
خارج سيطرته فيما يبقى السؤال هل ستتمكن
المؤسسات الدوليه من ضبط المساعدات واعاده
الاعمار في ظل ما يتعرض له الشعب السوري
من نكبات متواصله
[موسيقى]